so we should be live now
all right um thank you everybody for
dialing in and for coming to our meetup
tonight
so this is the 28th spidey the cambridge
meetup
and as has been the case for more than a
year now we're holding this one
online and as well as the
once in the foreseeable future
nevertheless we hope we have a an
interesting event for you tonight
so we have two talks um
i have a couple of slides and for the
meet up regulars
this will probably not be there will not
be too much
surprising in there and then we have
a talk by vincent varmadam who's going
to talk about
optimal benchmarks and other failures
a short break uh to allow for some
questions
maybe to get up and stretch your legs
and then another talk
by alexander senf who's going to talk to
us
about global alliance for genomics and
health
and just as a word of warning so the
meetup is recorded
if you're not comfortable with that feel
free to
leave the recording will be published
after the events
shortly after on youtube on our on or on
the pi data
channel and the link to that is at the
end of the slides
so a little bit of recap who are we
so we organize the pi data cambridge
meetup we've been
going strong since november 2018
now and we've managed to hold
monthly meetups every last wednesday of
the month
in the raspberry pi building when there
was a
an in-person meetup and now online
and the four organizers are except
myself
is federico leandro and olin
and we're all volunteers so
we like python we like data and
um we like doing data science and things
like that so
this is a volunteer effort we organize
things as you know
under the umbrella of the non-focus
organization
who sponsors us through pi data
as well as sponsoring many other open
source projects
and we're very grateful for their
ongoing support
so once again focus is um our
umbrella organization and our main
sponsor
so a couple of the non-focused projects
that
if you donate your your money goes
towards that you can help supporting
pretty much any um
well-known package in the ecosystem for
scientific data processing is there
going from numpy jupiter julia
and so on so if you like the meetup if
you like
this science with these packages please
consider donating and you find a link
at the bottom of the screen so we do
have
a code of conduct we ask that you behave
professionally
and gorgeously towards the other
participants
and just treat other people like you
want to be treated yourself
if you find that you
don't feel particularly comfortable in
the meetup and you think you've been
treated in a way that violates the code
of conduct
you can let us know or if you prefer to
take it up with a third party
you can contact leonie mook whose email
address is also given
at the bottom of the slides
and then last before we dive in
big thanks to our sponsors so our
sponsors keep making the meetup possible
and we currently have the following four
sponsors
they all get a chance to basically
tell us a little bit about what's going
on and
what they uh can do
and this may be also worth pointing out
that
for the time being even though we're not
handing out free pizza and beer
sponsorship is still very important
because there's
fees to pay for zoom for meetup and so
on
there's a little bit of overhead and
they help us cover that if you
apply for any any of the jobs that they
have listed on the next two slides
or if you contact them because of
something that came up in the meetup
please mention that um by data cambridge
is the reason why you found out and then
they can
see that their sponsorship is uh money
is well spent
so a couple of uh updates from our
sponsors arm
is looking for um a number of people to
to join various teams and the
job titles for open positions are listed
here as well as a
short description
you can find more information on the arm
careers page which
is also listed on the bottom of the
slide or you can talk to or contact
federico or leandro who are in this
meetup
and then um raspberry pi who when we
were still holding the meet up
in person kindly hosted us in their
fantastic building
um they have made the switch to to
online
and they're hosting weekly live streams
with educational activities
so if you're interested do join in
the link is listed on the slide rpf dot
io
home and you can interact with people
and talk about cool projects involving
raspberry pi
then our sponsor fetch.ai has a number
of
updates that they would like to share
with us so
they've released an alpha version of
their collective learning
framework on the github repository that
they have
and they have
codes that you can use or that you can
experiment with
or collaborate on that they would very
much like you to
test you out so there's an email address
if you want to
if you find something that is of
interest and you want to collaborate
that you can contact fetch.ai
on and they also have a discord
for ongoing discussions and
talks they also have a couple of
uh job opportunities for devops engineer
software engineer for basically
wide-ranging stack of technologies and
machine learning scientists and
engineers and you can find out more on
fetch.ai jobs
uh sorry okay and i
think that's it didn't skip any slides
um so to wrap it up um we are always
looking for speakers
in covet times more so than in
the normal times because it's harder to
go out and network with people so
if you know anybody who can be a speaker
for the meetup or if you want to
volunteer talk
to get in touch even if you're not
certain that
talk will be appropriate we love to
discuss and love to help you out
so the barriers is really low we're also
looking for sponsors as mentioned before
sponsorship fee makes a lot of things
possible so that's
very welcome as i mentioned the
recording of the meetup will be made
available
on the pi data youtube channel and you
can find the link
on the slides if you want to give us a
shout out over twitter or say how much
you enjoyed the meetup
please do so and tag us in it as well as
the
speakers and if there's anything that
you want to discuss or bring up
you also have our email address
so with that i will stop sharing
and i will
invite our first speaker vincent to
share his screen maybe just before i
give the introduction um i do want to
say and
i think most people have already
done that if you want to introduce
yourself in the chat box in the meantime
feel free to
to do so um and virtually high five each
other that's
that's great so our first speaker for
tonight
is vincent varmertam he is a
research advocate at rasa in the
netherlands
where he collaborates with the research
team to explain
and understand conversational systems
better
he's been evangelizing data and open
source for the last seven years
among others as one of the organizers
and actually co-founders of the pi data
amsterdam chapter
and he's here to tell us as the title
indicates
about optimal benchmarks and other
failures
thank you very much vincent for joining
us and the floor is yours
great um so just a few things to check
uh my audio is good that's the
yeah can hear you loud and clear cool
and like you can see me like do the
doodle here hopefully that's also
working okay
great uh that's everything we need for
the audio video segment
uh hi everyone my name is vincent uh i
work in raza and i would like to talk to
you today about
benchmarks um in short what i do at raza
is i'm a research advocate so that means
that
half my time is spent in doing stuff in
the research team
and the other half of the time is spent
doing stuff more on the
developer advocacy team another way to
sort of point it out and say well i'm
i'm kind of the interface with the
research team
and let's say like developers in our
community um
one thing that i'm especially keen on
supporting it's kind of like a task that
i've picked up myself within the
organization
is to make sure that we have plenty of
non-english tools in our natural
language processing stack
and it's this non-english thing that i
will also
shed a little bit of light on today um
but i'm
basically a person who tries to do both
of these two things and
um that means that part of what i do is
i have a youtube channel where i explain
all of our algorithms that's a pretty
big part of what i do
um but the role is also kind of natural
to me because
outside of you know rasa i'm also
involved with a whole bunch of open
source projects i maintain quite a few
of them
um and in particular what i would like
to talk to you about today
is why i felt the need that i should add
another one to the whole stack
but what i'll be talking about first and
foremost is just how i like to run
benchmarks
and in particular i would like to just
highlight this little tool called memo
that might be very useful
so from this point on everything that
i'll be doing now is just
code um these were all the slides that i
intended to show
so i'm about to show you the results of
a benchmark but before i go there i
would just like to talk about how a lot
of us do
benchmarks because you know we kind of
have to talk about this for loop that
we're all writing all over the place
every single day and like what i'm
hoping is that
there's some sort of recognition that
you have let's say a for loop that
calculates something
and then you start out with an empty
list
and then what's happening here is you
have this for loop and the for loop has
like the grid
like all the different settings and then
you have a function that calculates
something
but you're always appending something to
the list and then you have your
like data set the thing that you're
interested in we all write this for loop
daily and the thing is like what i've
got here is like a very silly simulation
experiment it's not necessarily super
fancy it's the birthday experiment
um like the number of people in your
class what's the probability that two
people share the same birthday that kind
of simulation
but even a simple function like this
gets annoying really quickly because
what i'm doing now is i have the class
size as a function input
as well as a number of simulations but
now if i want to maybe also tweak the
number of simulations
so then i have to do like four and sim
in
like i don't know some number of
simulations here
and then i got to do this indentation
thing and then i got to do this
number of simulations thing and you know
if i if i now do this depending this way
i still have a list of data but now i
got to worry about how do i link the
size parameter with the correct
measurement here and how do i link this
sim parameter with the correct
measurement here and very quickly this
for loop just becomes a mess
and i don't know about you but i've been
here before like at some point i just
noticed this pattern like vincent you
gotta stop doing this this is just silly
you just gotta abstract this away
okay so so here's what i here's what i
figured i would do
how's about this i'm just gonna say well
let's say that there's an
output here i'll call it proba and the
output is always a dictionary
let's just do that and let's just say
that i've got my data list here
somewhere
and then the only thing i might need is
from this library called memo
maybe i need to have a decorator called
mem list
and what i'll just go ahead and do is
i'll add a decorator to this one
function that calculates a whole bunch
of things
and then yeah i need to pass up this
data
like so and then the idea is every
single time that i run this
function it's just going to log all of
the inputs
as well as this output together and it's
just automatically going to append that
to this list
and then i'm done like i don't have to
worry about any of the for loops
just all the logging is taken care of
so that means if i now just manually run
this birthday experiment with a class
size of 10 the number similar
just i don't know just run this a couple
of times for a few settings let's just
do this
if i now look at my data list you'll see
that it's actually populated
which is nice but now if i turn it into
keyword arguments
uh let's do and sim here then everything
gets logged in once fell swoop
and what's nice about a list of
dictionaries is if i now import pandas
this list of dictionaries can always be
turned into a data frame
so that's that's pretty sweet and
another thing that's nice is
even if i don't want to have a data
frame this just totally allows for
you know if i have like another output
foo bar is equal to 42 like i can have
multiple outputs that's not a
boulder anymore but the main thing that
i like is i'm no longer fiddling around
with some sort of for loop
now this is this is just the idea called
memo like i just needed some sort of a
way to like deal with all this data
um but what's nice about the library is
i also allow you to like
have a couple of other fancy decorators
so for example
why do i log to just a list what i can
also do is i can log to
a file path so i can just say look this
is my results.json file
i would like to have everything logged
there and what i can also do is i can
have this
helper method that can generate this
grid for me with all the settings that i
want to loop over
uh you know i could turn it into a list
real quick but
basically these are all the different
settings that i'm interested in
and then what's pretty fancy is i can
also have like this little
bar that tells me the status and again
like i have my data set here and
it's just nice like this this is a nice
way to do grids
if i think about it
so also this is everything that memo
does the only thing that memo does it
gives you like a couple of fancy ways to
like handle your logging and some
helpers
right now i'm just sending it to files
and lists but there's also a setting
where you can send it to like a back end
like a web server so you just want to
log to like some sort of centralized
logging
thing that's also possible but this is
the idea behind this tool called
memo and so far you might think well
this is pretty neat but
i could also use grid search for this
since i decided learn right if i'm doing
so i could learn stuff then the grid
search should handle this and then the
grid search will also
paralyze and do all of those things and
you'd be kind of
right but let me talk about this one
exception to that
so as part of what i do with raza i try
to make sure that we have
plenty of support for non-english
languages and the people
feel free to play around with them i
also do a little bit of education there
so one of the projects that i maintain
on behalf of raza is this project called
what lies
and the whole idea behind this project
is that you can figure out
what lies in word embeddings or language
models
and these are the kinds of models where
you have some sort of text
and then you give that to some sort of
language model and what comes out for
that text is just this one little vector
and that's what word embeddings are
that's what language models are
and the only thing that what lies does
well there's a bunch of things but the
main thing that it does
is it gives the same interface to
translate a text to numeric vector
so if you're using byte pair embeddings
it's an interface but if even if you're
using hugging face it's the same
interface
this project makes sure that all these
different backhands just give you the
same
uh result and what's really cool about
it is that i was able to design
in such a way that this byte bypair
language this is like one of the
language backhands um it's one has
support for 275 languages by the way but
what's nice is you can just add that
into the cycle learn pipeline
and then this becomes a featurizer as
well so then you just say okay i want to
have the hugging face thing with
logistic regression
and you can still just use psychic learn
no need to learn the hugging face thing
and this just works
so it's great but
this language back end i mean it depends
on how it's been implemented
but you cannot assume that you can
pickle it
like it might be written in c or c plus
or something fancy
it's probably not something that's
completely written in python
and if you cannot pickle it then you
cannot serialize it
and it also means that grit search will
no longer work
the big caveat with grid search inside
of scikit-learn is that everything needs
to be serializable
and you cannot guarantee that for you
know very fancy machine learning
pipelines like these language pipelines
so the reason why i started working on
memo was
hey i was just tired of the for loops
like it drove me nuts
but the other reason is also that there
are these moments like this one
where grid search is just not entirely
what you're interested in
and what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to zoom in on a benchmark that
i was running it's like the thing in
particular that i'll be talking about
for the rest of this talk but i hope
that people look at memo and sort of go
like oh yeah it's kind of
kind of neat and i hope that people also
understand like hey there's merit to
having like these language backhands and
uh go to the what lies website uh i
support over 275 languages with this
thing
and if anyone has questions about it
feel free to reach out to me on twitter
as well
i'd love to hear feedback
but the idea is uh i have this task this
classification task
and i'll just show you the benchmark
that i'm running high over and then
we'll see how memo fits into all of this
but
the idea is i have some sort of a data
set
uh it's just a classification task and
then i would like to pass in a string
for a
represents a model um
there's also some sort of embedding i
would like to use there's a train size
as a test size and
basically this is a function where all
the logic is happening in
but the main thing that's important is
that i have this function over here
that generates the model on my behalf
and this generate model generates the
thing that i will then call dot fit on
which later i will do some predictions
with and then at the end
i'll return like the like the accuracy
the stuff that you're typically
interested in
but the main thing that's important is i
have a function where strings are able
to go in
and all the logic that needs to happen
for the benchmark is happening on the
inside
here and in particular i have this
really
sort of silly function over here that
can generate the model where
it's just a bunch of dictionaries and a
couple of like these cached scikit-learn
pipelines
i am using the universal sentence
encoder here i'm using fast text
embeddings over here
and i've got this setting here where i'm
just using count vectors to sort of
encode my text
but what's nice about memo again is i'm
like super flexible in how i do this
like i'm not constrained by
how the grid search likes to have things
before i can make a grid i can just
define
everything with functions and at the
very bottom what i just do
is i have this giant grid and i have all
sorts of settings that i'm looping over
so i've got
fast text and universal sentence encoder
etc
now i'm doing something in this
benchmark that most papers
don't do but it is something that i
highly
recommend i'm doing two things that are
kind of interesting
for starters i'm comparing fast text in
the universal sentence encoder which
are two fancy sort of embedding
techniques
but i'm comparing that basically against
the simplest thing you can do which is
just count vectors
just encode every word as one or a zero
and give a giant array of sparse things
to a logistic regression
most papers that i read on text
classification
and like say they are benchmarks don't
do this
but we'll keep that in mind another
thing that i'm doing
is i'm also saying well you know i do my
proper trained test split
but i'm also kind of interested in just
the effect of the train sides
like maybe certain embeddings work
better if you don't have a lot of data
and other types of embeddings work
better if you have a lot of data
there's something to be said for that
and usually if you have a
proper benchmark in a paper they just
assume a big train set and a big
test set but they don't do this extra
little step that says hey let's just
check
if the size of the training set even
matters
okay so you know um this is i have the
script
it's on my server the server is going
going
and then at some point i have my results
now
there's a couple of ways of doing your
results but i'll just show you some
tricks that i like
you um what i've got here is basically
i'm opening up my
my log files like i showed before this
is just on disk but i'm opening up in
pandas
and after that i'm giving that to a tool
called high plot
and high plot is a really really likable
tool if you haven't seen it before
the idea is that i have parallel
coordinates here
um and for all the different parameters
i can do
queries so one thing i can do is i can
say well give me
i don't know the examples where the
prediction time was super high
and then okay you can kind of see that
it's because i'm using this one sort of
embedding over here okay i know that's
interesting
but what's even cooler is i can say well
let's select a portion of the train size
and let's see how all the other metrics
change as i increase the train size
you could be like really fancy and say
oh no let's make like a sub selection on
multiple axes like that's the cool thing
about this visualization you could very
quickly
make these cuts but in the interest of
time the main thing i would like to draw
your attention to
is you'll notice that there's like a lot
of high accuracy tests here
but i would like to keep your eye on
this axis
so i'm going to increase the training
size but then let's see what happens to
the accuracy in my train set
when i do that so i'm first selecting
train sizes that are low we see that the
accuracy over here they're all
like super high in the train set but as
i move this up
notice that the accuracy in the train
set actually kind of goes down
now obviously you know this is all
within like one percent
so we shouldn't really claim too many
things here anyway
but the fact that you have this
interaction makes this a really cool
tool to play with and that's something i
just found really interesting
so i just really quickly wanted to show
you this because if you haven't seen
this tool before like hype fault is
really really sweet
it's really good for this sort of thing
it's nice and fast
but in this particular case i figured
you know it's you know this all this
stuff is interesting
but if i select like the best performing
things here i very quickly come to the
conclusion that maybe it's not really
the embedding that's doing the work it's
maybe just a train size if i'm honest
okay so if that's the case and i should
make a plot with the train size on the
x-axis and
sort of see what happens um
and i like it when things are like you
know interactive so
i'm using altair for the charting here
and what i'm showing you here
is the results from the fast text
embeddings and the universal sentence
encoder
and i don't know about you but let's
zoom in on this
right now let's zoom in here in the
beginning
so there's like maybe a percentage
difference right in the beginning
maybe
and same here at the end my main
percentage difference
but to now start yelling like hey my
universal sentencing code that's state
of the art i mean that'd be kind of a
failure
you'd be dismissing the fact that a lot
of the things that you're doing here
depend on the size of your training set
like that's the thing that's causing the
uplift
compared to the size of the training set
like this
is small beings
and when i'm at it i mean what i can
also do now is i can say well
i'm only comparing fast text to the
universal sentence encoder now
should i maybe you know rerun this whole
thing but
also with the engrams like the basic
count factor trick
can i just take that and when i do that
i mean now we're really gonna have to
zoom in now
but now when you zoom in
you really really gotta zoom in like a
lot
to even spot a difference between fast
text and these count vectors
like you really really gotta zoom in
this is like a uh
order of magnitude to the power of minus
five
like difference in performance here
right so
so so okay you know i'm doing the
benchmarks i think in a cool way i'm
using memo i'm using all sorts of fancy
tricks here and all that stuff is nice
but if i were to now sort of look at
this and if i were to ask myself the
question like is this a meaningful
benchmark am i doing something clever
here
then i hope you would agree that you
know the main thing that i should be
doing
is i should maybe estimate you know
the velocity that i still have here and
maybe
see if i can propagate that forward and
maybe do some more labeling
but i really shouldn't be bragging too
much about these embeddings like that's
not
that's not really the thing that's
driving this forward and i want to
mention this explicitly because i am
really disappointed at all of these
research papers
that say oh yeah we have a data set
that's like 2 000 labels and 50 classes
and universal sentencing coda works best
i mean that's great
but your velocity is still super big
here like you should focus on training
data you shouldn't
focus on these machine learning models
it's um it's not the most effective
thing you could do
but it even gets worse um i've only
shown you some quick tools now but what
i haven't done
is i haven't talked to you about what
i'm even doing like i've not talked
about the data set at all yet
um but the data set that i have here
it's it's not a bad data set but it's a
intense data set
the idea here is i have lots of let's
just show you like a few examples
i guess that makes it quite clear
usually
but it's a data set kind of like hey um
i've got a sentence here how would you
say fly in italian
and if this is a text you would give to
an assistant the assistant
should say oh like your intent is you
want to translate like that's the class
that i should associate with this
sentence like that's the task that i'm
sort of benchmarking here
and you know if i if i then have a look
at all of these labels and if i don't
say well let's do a value count on that
and let's then also turn it into a
dictionary then and i can sort of see
how many examples i have
for all these different intents okay
sure i've got 150 examples per intent
that's not bad
but i mean there's an intent for paying
the bill
there's an intent for bad spelling for
setting an alarm
for whisper mode to confirm reservations
to check your flight status this doesn't
represent an actual virtual assistant
this is like 150 different intents
there's like all of them
almost like all the standard ones that
you might find in maybe 20
chat bots but this doesn't represent a
single virtual assistant
i mean think about it this way it
becomes even more silly to sort of
hyper optimize for one of these data
sets
and and the main lesson here of course
is like
reality is way more complex than a csv
file ever will be
and we really got to be careful that
we're not fooling ourselves when we're
doing these benchmarks right because
it's
it's not just on sort of the practical
level of the hey reality is complex but
also just you know
grit search is just so easy to fool you
and sort of you're chasing the wrong
rabbit
and with that in mind i started thinking
about this new open source package that
maybe i should start writing if we're
talking about what rabbit you gotta
chase
you know maybe we should uh
take a step back because
if nothing else what i've learned from
this benchmark is that maybe these
sparse tools they just work
fine for a lot of situations
maybe not very complex ones but there's
a lot of situations where
you know taking your text and passing it
through a sparse array and
just giving that to a machine learning
model will just do the trick it might
just get you to 90
accuracy then you get a lot of
interpretability so maybe we should just
figure out ways to make this better so i
started wondering about that like what
can you do here
well one thing that we can do is we can
maybe start thinking about this partial
fit phenomenon
so inside could learn not every model
has this but there are these models that
don't just do
fit predict but there are also models
that do a partial fit
the idea there is is that you're able to
say well let's split my data set up into
chunks
and let's first train the model on this
portion then on this portion and then on
this one
with the whole idea that you don't need
to have the entire data set in memory at
all times you could just train on like
micro batches
and sort of stream through an entire
file and then be done with it
but the standard circuit learned
pipeline doesn't really allow for that
status i could learn is fit predict and
even if we have transformers that allow
for this partial fit
you know we kind of needed a new
pipeline for this
so i made this tool and the tool is
called
tokenweiser and it's just some
scikit-learn compatible
tools that allow you to sort of play
around with tokens in a bit more of a
flexible way
and the first thing the first feature
that we provide is we have a partial
pipeline it's a pipeline that allows for
this
partial fit which means that you can
train on these separate batches
instead of one single batch
and scikit-learn then has a hatching
vectorizer and an
sgd classifier that you can put in and
they will just work
out of the box and you can train these
models by like on a streaming more
settings it's not really streaming but
it's close to it
the other thing that we also do let's
just start running some cells
the other thing that we can also do is
we can then start thinking like hey do
we have like transformers we can put in
here
that sort of make it easier for us to
find interesting patterns in text
now one thing that people typically like
to talk about is like hey let's do the
n-gram trick
where we're going to take every single
sub word and encode that into a huge
sparse array
and if we do that we're robust against
spelling errors
because even if we don't hit on like one
of these sub words we might still hit on
all the other ones
i know that's fine but like you might
have this super huge sparse array
so instead what you might want to do is
say like let's just take text
and let's just split the text up due to
like hyphenation
so it's ah straw
logie i guess the way you would
pronounce a word
and maybe if we can take like a normal
word like this one
and then transform it into this well
then the hash vectorizer would know
these are the three sub words to just go
ahead and
vectorize no need to like have these
huge sparse arrays anymore
and when you have a sentence like
megaton dinosaur head it becomes megaton
dinosaur head and you know there's
things to be liked about here another
thing that you can do is you can use the
the yake trick yake is a library that
does text summarization it tries to find
um portions in text that are the most
important
so if you are dealing with long news
articles this can be a way to like
summarize that in the small form uh jake
is a pretty cool tool for that
um but you know what's even nicer is
that we also have like feature union
tools
so you can make very complex pipelines
where first we clean the data like we
remove all
weird spelling weird characters and then
we keep the string as is and then
combine it with the hyphenated text i
mean you can
you can build pipelines whatever way you
like it
and there's some extra tools i would
just like to mention here let's just
show them real quick due to time
i am almost over like some other things
that i
think were pretty neat to have here as
well we have phonetic preparation tools
so
what we encode is not the text but
rather what it sounds like
so we have these data banks that tell
you what a word sounds like in english
so we can also encode to that might also
be robust against certain spelling
errors
we can also use a tool like spacey to
say what part of speech a word is
this way the word duck as a verb is
different than the word duck as a noun
which is also useful information to
encode
if we're using spacey we can also
lemmatize the text so that means that we
get the infinitive
of a verb instead of the entire verb so
it can also reduce your vocabulary
there's lots of these tricks that i just
want to have in the library
and as of today you can pip install
token wiser
and these can be already some tools you
can go ahead and play with
so i have three minutes left
and that brings me to this other thing
that this library
also does this is the steve jobs there's
one more thing moment
so this partial fit right
that's kind of an uncommon way of doing
things inside of psychic learn
but if you think about it a lot of
machine learning tools actually do work
this way
like most neural networks they train on
these batches and that's sort of the way
that they expect things to run
there is this other very popular open
source package out there
called spacey and i started wondering
you know which
pipeline do i like most whenever i'm
doing simple benchmarks so like so i
could learn more do i like spacey more
and especially with space e3 i'm kind of
inclined to say well
i don't think psychedler is for
everything anymore i think there's some
stuff i just want to do in spacey
nowadays
ah but man i would really like it if i
could use my old tricks
the thing is because spacey does deep
learning things
the only way spacey will train is by
using this partial
fit mechanic so you cannot do standards
i can learn pipelines inside a space you
just can't
unless you use tokenwiser
because one of the things that we can do
inside a token wiser
is we can say well let's just follow the
new standard
spacey setting registry that's a new
feature don't have enough time to
go into there but in short what we do
allow you to do now
using this library is we allow you to
say well here's a partial pipeline
it has to be a partial pipeline you have
to have the partial fit thing in here
and what you can then do is you can say
well let's just link that
and from here you should be able to just
run the standard spacey train loop
but you can have scikit-learn inside of
spacey and use psychic learn as a
benchmark and that's the badass thing
spacey has some lovely models some of
them are
somewhat heavyweight but it's nice to do
this
super simple thing with just this bag of
tricks
to just have the benchmark there so that
you know when you
so that you know the base rate so you
also know that you might not need
something that's super complex
and that's what i'm trying to do with
this library i'm trying to just have
you know that the slogan for the project
is token wiser it's a bag of tricks not
words
um but the goal of this project is to
just have a sort of
a place to celebrate the fact that we
can keep things simple maybe we just
need a couple of these tricks instead
and the main thing that i'm really
trying to prevent here is
this i want to prevent these kinds of
failures where we are really fooling
ourselves that we're doing
state-of-the-art
uh well instead we're just solving the
wrong problem
um so tokenweiser what lies memo these
are all things that i'm working on
some of these tools i'm building on
behalf of raza some of these tools i'm
building on behalf of myself
but i hope that this is giving people
food for thought and
uh here's the fancy logo i designed for
this project
i hope people find this interesting i
have a little road map of things i would
like to do
uh one of the things i will also do is i
will add support for vocal wabbit
which is also this really cool tool
works via sort of the same
training procedure i mentioned before
also a streaming trick
but this is what one of the hobby
projects that i'm currently working on
and i'm hoping this is useful to other
people
would be a great time for questions i
have a q a s sort of chat thing open but
i didn't see any questions pop in
i don't know if that's a separate oh
wait chat now i see
there you go um
i don't see any questions yet we'll give
people a bit of time to
collect their thoughts but in the
meantime i wanted to ask a quick
question
um so i want to latch on to the last
thing that you said tokenwizar is a
bag of tricks
do you have an interface if i have a
trick of my own that i want to add
to to token wiser like is there a base
class to to implement
or a specific api so i
the only thing i do is i i integrate
with psychic learn i integrate with
spacey
that's it so as long as your trick is
cycled or compatible i think we're good
okay um and like you have to convince me
that it's a trick that i'm willing to
support like
if you have a fancy like bird model then
this is not going to be the package for
it
right what lies is going to be the
package for that
okay and there's some extra stuff i
didn't have time to discuss but the main
idea is like uh spacey so i could learn
tricks
and an exchange between that like that's
what i'm trying to do here
and also like just because you're
cambridge i just uh to all the arm
and raspberry pi people you rock
like this is fun toys man i just wanted
to like
i don't know if there are any employees
in the room but just one of them said
like that's really cool
i stuff there's probably a fair bit i
would assume so
but um
but yeah there's no more questions then
there's no more questions i guess
i have a actually another question if
you don't mind go ahead
to go back to the beginning of your
presentation you showed the
the grid generator
this one yeah exactly
um do you have any um
thoughts about supporting generating
um bags of parameters that are not
regularly spaced where maybe you
even take into account how your
experiment um
behaves oh great so there's a random
grid
um i i've added it because i knew that
this question would come in a
presentation some sometime which
is happening now having said that i
never really use it
and again that's because i i experience
these grid search differently i'm really
not going for state of the art
instead what i'm doing here is i'm
probing i'm trying to understand the
underlying system a bit better
i think that's my primary goal i'm not
doing like the bayesian optimization
thing
typically and i would might also argue
that yes i
i have found a use case with machine
learning for this memo library
uh but one of the features is also that
uh
you can do a grid thing and then log to
a server so it's it's not really tied to
machine
it's not meant to be super tight in
machine learning and if i recall
correctly i think
rich is like the only dependency i have
on this project because of this fancy
uh progress bar um like
nothing is stopping you from like doing
a grid looking at the data frame
defining a new grid and doing that loop
yourself but the hyperop is not the goal
here it's just
um making things a whole lot a whole log
simpler
that's what i'm trying to do here thank
you
meantime i think we have two more
questions in the q a box
i'll i'll answer the the last one what
motivates you to start these projects
and are they used externally or just
inside raza
my other question what languages does
raza work on okay so the first question
is
um i do know that they're actually used
so there's this website called
we can check actually epi.tech
so if i type what lies in here then you
see the download numbers so
what lies has a couple of couple hundred
downloads a week
uh this is not like massive or anything
but i do know it's being used
uh memo is like fairly recent we have
like 100 downloads a week which is not
nothing but it's also
not like i mainly wrote it for myself i
just don't mind open sourcing it
so the thing that motivates me is just i
have an itch i want to scratch it
what lies came to be because i had an
itch that was work related
and then my boss said oh yeah let's open
source that that's something we can
share and other people are going to find
it useful
um now as far as like the languages that
raza works on we typically try to be
language agnostic
like anything that we don't the main
thing i try to do
is if there's a tokenizer missing for a
specific language and i figure out a way
to maybe add that to raza
like that's some of the stuff that i do
on a day-to-day basis like
you just have to notify me that
something's missing and i'll try to
figure it out
all the tools that raza makes in general
like we integrate with spacey quite
directly
so you could say yeah that's that's a
lot of european languages but in general
we try to support everything it's hard
but we don't have a language preference
uh someone else said i had a use case
used so i could learn nearest neighbor
retrievals benchmark against
annoy well we used token wise every
string way of doing that city tree for
retrieval since both annoy
work well um
i mean i've benchmarked annoy against
scikit-learn's nearest neighbor and noy
just
typically wins um will i be able to use
tokenwiser to have a streaming way
of doing that using psycholearn's kd3
i don't know if psychic learns kd3 has a
streaming setting i think it just has
fits not fit partial not not partial fit
um feel free to ask me that question in
more detail on twitter
i think i'm not 100 sure uh
what you mean with the question but feel
free to reach out to me and i'll check
it out in more detail
and if people are interested by the way
like if people want to like
play around with another tool with
another itch that i scratched um
just for fun google human learn that is
just google it
and uh i think if you like the shortest
preview one of the things that it
features is um
you can like actually draw a machine
learning model
uh which is then also psych and learn
compatible just saying if you haven't if
you haven't used it yet this uh this
tool is pretty sweet
also itch i wanted to scratch
also someone said state of the art and i
just drew a model instead
i think that's it for questions right
yeah thank you very much
um that was really great um my pleasure
if there's any other questions for
vincent that come up or we have our
second talk
feel free to post them as well um
vincent if you
are able to stay with us a little bit
longer
and there are questions feel free to
answer them but
if not people can reach out to you on
twitter and keep the discussion going
yes add me on twitter and
i'll stop sharing the screen thanks
so with that it's time for our second
speaker of the
evening um we have alexander sent
up next so alexander we didn't try
sharing your slides but if you could
try sharing your screen and you can see
if that works
host disabled participant screen sharing
i need to do more black magic
all right can you try again yes
awesome thanks well you get
set up um let me introduce our next
speaker of the evening
so our speaker is alexander zenfone
alexander is a principal bioinformatics
software engineer
at congenica here in cambridge and he's
also the task
chair for the crypt for gh encrypted
file format standards
and prior to joining congenica alexander
and i were actually colleagues
at ntot for a while and he is here to
tell us about
ga4gh which is the global alliance for
genomics and health take it away
alexander
thank you yeah so today my my goal is
really to to introduce
the gfrgh as an organization
um what it does and
if you're working in the bioinformatics
space maybe you've come across it
maybe not but i just want to
hopefully gather some interest here and
then
help you to explore what we are doing in
here
um so even
even now working at a genomics health
company i noticed that
the gfrgh is not really a well-known
organization
even though if you work in the space you
probably have used
standards that have been either designed
or supported by the gfrgh
so where did it all start really
um i want to start out simply by saying
that the way
what it stands for is the global
alliance for genomics and health so it's
an organization that tries to promote
human health through the use of genomics
and in its founding documents they refer
back to
the un charter of human rights which
contains a clause that says that every
human
has the right to benefit from scientific
progress
i think about 167-ish countries have
ratified that in 1976
so technically this would be a legally
actionable right that every human has
in most countries on earth and
to to benefit in terms of your health
from genomic research
falls under that so that's one of the
preambles of of the g4g age
and it tries to achieve that primarily
by enabling
the sharing of genomic data so
going back to really the mid 1990s here
when
when we started having like the sanger
method of getting genome
data what a lot of people noticed
is that a lot of labs started to create
genomic data
they stored it it was new at the time
so every every lab independently created
their own formats
they siloed their data they didn't share
it
which it's understandable for a new
field
but the people especially if you reach
the mid
and we see the start of the human genome
project if you try to project forwards
you can already see that the genomic
data would have a huge
impact or it was at least believed it
would have a huge impact on
understanding human health and also
developing therapies and so on
so even back as far as the 1990s there
were people
already concerned about the ecosystem
that would allow us to share this data
and that includes data formats
that includes the policy that allows
sharing data that
includes um the willingness of people to
share data and so on
um you've seen in incidents of that
um during the human genome project so
for example
once craig vento for example joined um
he wanted to keep all the data private
and charge money for access to it
whereas the the open consortium people
were adamant that everything had to be
publicly available to support science
and encourage progress
so this kind of um
this discussion has been going on for a
long time
um eventually in 2013 this led to the
formation of the gfrgh and a lot of the
people
who were involved in it for the past 20
30 years were part of this
so that that really goes back in its
origins a long way
i'm having a lot of links in this
presentation please feel free to contact
me if you want them so you don't really
have to
write them down but the main goal of the
g4 gh
is to develop open standards
sharing for example if i sequence that
data
that you can read it with the tools you
prefer to use
but that goes beyond um the technical
standards it also goes into policy so
for example
if i do sequence a human genome
would i even be allowed to share it
outside my borders
under what conditions can you use data
what kind of
information can i include if i have
phenotype what is their public
identifiable information and not
so these kind of policy questions that
gfrgh also tries to address
um as an organization the it is actually
fairly small
so there's a small dedicated staff and
nearly everyone within the organization
actually has a main job
and does ga4gh work as
part of that main job the dedicated
organization mostly supports planning
planning of conferences support
providing zoom meeting rooms
etc but by and large
the idea is to have it embedded
not only in in research work
but throughout projects that happen in
in industry in academia
in national uh initiatives and so on
and in addition to that we reach out to
to volunteers and really anyone who is
interested
so in order to participate in what the
j4h is doing you
do not have to be a member of the gfrgh
you don't have to work for a member for
the g4 gh it is really is open and
anyone is
is encouraged to participate and
contribute
both to the development of standards as
well as for the development of codes
etc but the goal really is to do
something
that is useful in this space so it's not
a standardization organization
that creates standards that may or may
not be useful
but and they're done with it um on the
contrary
um a standard will only be developed or
supported if it actually has
a real use case and and if it is
actually actively being used by the
community and if there is interest in it
um if you have if you want to see an
overview of all the different kinds of
standards they have
there's various links most of them start
with gfogh.org so that is a great
website
to get more information if you're
interested about the
individual bits i'll talk about the
individual components in a little bit
so the way it is organized
is you have from the ga4gh organization
on the left hand side
each standard is grouped within a work
stream
so we have the discovery work stream
with which deals
with how do i find the date i'm
interested in
which is not easy especially if you're
dealing with
30 40 different databases you might want
to search
but it's especially hard if you're
dealing with access controlled databases
so if you if you're looking for a
specific allele
for some genomic research you're doing
how on earth would you find that allele
um currently you have to read papers
and then these papers link to data sets
and you can go to these data sets and
archives
but there is an effort to make this a
bit more discoverable so that you have
tools that would allow you
to get an idea oh it's in this data set
and then you may apply for access to
that data set
without with the data still remaining
safe
we have large-scale genomics which deals
with how do we handle
the data we're working with this is
primarily
file formats am sam cram etc
and also the cryptographic file format
click 4gh which i'm working in
um the data used in research id this is
more for
the combined policy and a technical
issue
um this deals with
if you are a researcher and how do we
know you are a researcher
what what what kind of id would
would tell me that you're a bona fide
researcher in other words
and data use tries to come up with an
automated system
of classifying how you want to use data
and both of those together hopefully
will enable
access decisions towards access control
databases
on a more automated basis because
currently
if you want access to an access mobile
database you apply to an
access committee they review your
application
say yes or no it's a manual process so
it doesn't scale very well
there's a cloud stream uh more and more
of what we're doing happens in the cloud
so in order to make that useful
easy to use scalable um it's an
important aspect
and even more important than that if i
run an analysis on my laptop
if i run it in the cloud if i run it in
a different cloud i always want to get
the same results back
so that the workflow that i have is
scalable
and here the idea is eventually the data
sets become too large
so you want to be able to take your
workflow put it next to the data
run it there get back the result rather
than downloading the data
and running it locally but it has to
always produce the same results
um genomic knowledge standards things
like
variant interpretation if you find a new
variant within a gene
what does it mean and how do you
actually
write down and share that knowledge in
in a way that
others can understand it and then
finally clinical and phenotypic data
capture
this is an interesting bit because dfrgh
started
as a research organization clearly with
a view towards going into the clinical
space as well
and that head is actually quite a huge
gap it has to bridge here and clinical
is has evolved in a different way than
research but we still have to be able to
share data between those domains and
make sure we understand what each other
mean
ontologies the terminology
interpretation data
things like that and in addition to that
there's a regulatory and ethics and a
data security work stream
those simply are there to ensure that
the standards that are being
developed and promoted and supported um
follow certain minimum requirements
on the top side we have real world
projects
so here it is important that whatever we
develop is being used
again we do not want to create standards
for
us and sitting on a shelf somewhere so
every
participant works on an actual research
project on an actual academic project on
an actual
industrial project and contributes that
work to the g4gh and that way
the standards that are being developed
are already being used
at that point but it is something that
has real world application that is real
world code and support
and so on if i go closer towards
cambridge if i look at who's involved in
in the local area here
so we have genomics england which is a
contributor as well as a user of
standards
they're using standard like hts get
which allows you to access genomic data
via api
but just the regions that you need we
don't have to download everything
we have the welcome sanger institute
which participates to a lot of the work
streams
and and the many of the maintainers of
the file formats
are at the center um then the european
bioinformatics institute
ebi uh also it has so many institutes
within the edi that participate in so
many work streams
that we almost cover the entire range of
uh work that happens and also elixir
europe
um all of these happen to be on the
genome campus near cambridge
but that doesn't mean that the work only
happens there so there's collaborations
with cambridge university which
contribute there's collaborations with
industries such as illumina which also
contribute
so it really is is fairly pervasive in
at least in the biodramatic space
around here but also worldwide
now in order to
work with the ga4gh the first thing you
have to find out is what is that that
you're actually interested in
and there's a list of all the work
streams um
they are described in in more detail
uh toward more than i can just say here
there's also road maps in what they're
trying to achieve
um in in the time frames
and within each workstream road map
there's then
a link to meeting minutes which
in those there's a link to each of the
subtasks
and that's where the actual work is
taking place so each subtask
deals with one standard each of them has
their own
zoom meeting that happens every month
each of them has their own standards
documentation
which is in a github repository each
standard has
implementations hopefully we have links
to them within
the repos
but all of that is really open in public
so
if you are curious about let's say you
want to use the cram
file format you would just go to that
page
find the cram meeting and just join it
the zoom link the zoom details are there
and everyone is is welcome and
encouraged to support
uh and join in addition to that we have
other outreach so there's plenty of
workshops going on
our primary outreach is an annual
plenary conference
which happens in in the autumn every
year
and in the spring every year we have a
sort of a smaller leadership oriented um
conference
and and that is important because by now
we have so many different work streams
and so there are
many different people working on
standards it is
really hard to keep an overview and so
in those connect meetings
we're trying to mix up those groups and
make sure that each standard that is
being developed actually
is compatible with each other which as
we're growing and growing
gets harder
um it is also important
one thing that is necessary for a
standard to exist is there have to be
implementations
so again that goes back to what we are
trying to
standardize has to be usable and part of
the usability is that you can just go
out
have an implementation work with it
immediately
so there have to be two reference
implementations however
what the da4gh delivers and stands
behind is
just the standard itself but not the
software
um what the product is in the end is a
standards document
such as vcf 4.3 there's a pdf file that
clearly outlines what the what standard
looks like
and that's what is certified by the cfo
gh
if you write software that implements
that standard we would link to it
it would probably be used throughout the
community
but saying that there is an
implementation does not imply that the
g4 gh has audited the code
or or any of that sort of thing so
it's always a difference keep in mind
and that's particularly important
when dealing with a security oriented uh
standard
such as like a cryptographic file format
you
you still have to take proper care about
the code you're using
but only that it fulfills the the
standards that are set out but also that
the implementation itself
follows minimum requirements
so i thought maybe an interesting way to
go through
how the gfrgh works is to go through
how a standard comes into being um the
standard that i'm a
task chair of is a crypt for gh which
is a file format that is encrypted
but it allows you to use the data in the
same way as if
it was unencrypted so if you add it to
your tool
you can read and write encrypted data
and it's only decrypted in main memory
for the time
it is being used and i want to
briefly go over how we came to
proposing and then going through
implementing that standard
so what is the path that is from a
thought of we think it's a good idea to
an actual standard
and as a quick background on how we came
to the idea of starting this
is just going back to the ega that is
the
that's one of the sub teams in in the
european bioinformatics institute
and the ega is the european genome
freedom archive which is one of the
archives that keep human genetic data
for research
purposes it's one of the largest
in the world it's counterpart to dd gap
in the u.s
and ddbj in japan and
those three really capture the vast
majority of human genetic data for
research
so when i started working there
10 years ago i think one of the
well next slide actually so
what we do is we we accept data it has
been used in
papers for publications journals usually
require you to make the data available
and journals often require that you have
an ega accession id
or a dbgap accession id
to verify that the data will be publicly
available once the
paper is published so you submit the
data to the ega
it does not become the ownership of ega
you
remain the owner of the data that means
in order to get access you have to
nominate a data access committee that
will make decisions later on
on who the data will be shared with and
the ega
holds the data on your behalf and it
distributes the data
on your behalf it means as
as archive it has the responsibility to
keep the data safe
secure and also make it available in an
easy and
quick way
the
one of the components of keeping the
data safe is we keep it encrypted in our
archive at all times
if you download it it arrives on your
computer in an encrypted format
then it passes over into your
responsibility so once you download the
data from the ega
you're now responsible for keeping it
safe
which takes very diff uh different
shapes and forms
so we have had clients who would
download the data
put it in an hpc environment which
doesn't have the red internet
connectivity then decrypt it and use it
there so
that's super secure can't really
complain at all about that
on the other end of the spectrum you
have users smaller users who download
your data
download it to a laptop decrypt it use
it and then it lists on the laptop
or it lives on a shared group drive and
we don't really know what happens there
we don't really know who has access we
don't really know what happens if your
laptop gets stolen
and so those are the sort of two
extremes of what happens once the data
is accessed
um and it's a bit frustrating to see
because we have really no control over
that as an archive
but it would be nice if you could extend
the security of the data a little bit so
so the question is
how can we encourage users to be a bit
more secure with the data they receive
from the archive
how can we extend the security of the
data beyond the archive into the actual
usage
one option of course is keep the data
encrypted
at all times if possible um
and make this encryption transparent to
the end user because
in many cases uh the users who download
the data and run analyses
are not technically versed so they
wouldn't be able to
to run the decryption or to have some
complicated commands that allow you to
access
um intermediates that allow you to
access the data
so it that's always sort of a bit of
attention between keeping it secure and
easy to use
so that brings me back to when i started
at the ega one of the first
tasks i had was to actually think about
a way of encrypting the data for the
archive
that allows us to index it and also
decrypt only components of it
from at the time when i started
everything was gpg encrypted
so if you wanted to access a little bit
of it you'd have to decrypt the whole
thing
we wanted to be able to access only
parts of the data so that we could work
on them within the archive
without having huge staging spaces of
constantly encrypting and decrypting
data
and i didn't actually have to do very
much here because the
aes standard already existed
if i use aes counter mode i can encrypt
and decrypt
aes blocks at will plus
the aes data is an xor of the plane data
so any
any index files i had would already be
valid on the
encrypted data as well but that gave me
time to actually write tools to use
aes data so i wrote tools to encrypt it
to allow users to prepare submissions to
the archive
i wrote tools to to download the data i
wrote some microservices to use
internally to access the data all of
that is
is still available in the ega github
archive it's all some
java code that i wrote a long time ago
um the interesting idea here is
that they download client so i built in
a client that allowed you to download
data and to decrypt it
but i also um packaged a java based fuse
layer onto it
so you could download the data leave it
encrypted start the fuse layer
and it would decrypt the data as you
accessed it and only the portions of
data you accessed so it would never
write unencrypted data to disk
which i thought was a great idea um i
also created
a fork of the hds jdk library that would
allow you to open a bam file
or a cram file directly from the
encrypted stage
and use it so here the decryption would
happen as hts jdk would read the data
and so on
so these are these are all great tools
and they would be
so the idea is if users would actually
use them
they could keep the data encrypted and
still use it with their normal tools
and then it would actually be secure and
safe even if you store it on your laptop
and lose it
however the issue is here all of these
tools we had to write ourselves
as egi archive it is it is
understandably kind of impossible to go
somewhere else and say
hey i've come up with this way of
dealing with data
and you add it to your code so the
question here became how can we take
something that already works but make it
into something that
might even be extended into the
ecosystem so that
a tool developer might come and say
here's a new file format i can add this
to my code
and and then it's a supported native
part of my tool
that's when the idea started of creating
a file
format that would formalize all of these
things in a way that the community
accepts
um so the first step in this project was
to identify
if this need that we saw is a real need
and so as we started to develop this
product um that's how
standards the terminology of standards
are used for in the g48
the first thing we had to do was to
create a product review committee
and the requirement was that it was
comprised of people from various work
streams
um to ensure that i'm not just
hitting my close friends and they say
it's a great idea so it has to be
accepted as a good idea across
many different work streams so we ended
up having someone from
abroad institute who had someone from
epfl in switzerland
and then also within the ebi from the
vcf
file format standard product review
committee
so they then have to listen to you
explain what you're trying to do
and actually agree that this is an idea
that has
usage for the entire community not just
for a very small niche
nobody would use it
so you work with them to develop a
description of what it is that you're
trying to set out to do
this will also have to have some initial
reviews by the regulatory and ethics
work stream
uh just to make sure that you're within
any regulatory environments
that might be affected um ethics it's
part of
the whole kind of work that we're doing
with human genome data
a security work stream is quite
important here
they were actually our our strongest
critics in the beginning simply saying
have you looked at this one have you
looked at homomorphic encryption have
you looked at secure third-party
computing
have you considered this so they were
very very strict in
having us do our preparation properly
which was um
actually pretty good and then one of the
things you also
have to prepare to do outreach and
partner engagement later on
um again so that the the standard
actually that's being
promoted throughout the community being
used
um there must also be two maintainers
who write
implementations and maintain the
standard throughout its lifetime
then you write a proposal once
everything has been signed off by the
various committees and
send it to the steering committee the
steering committee is literally a
cross-section of academia and industry
that's the leadership across all the
different work streams
they look at the documentation and vote
on it
so they also have to agree that this is
something worthwhile pursuing
and if it is accepted you then get some
administrative support so you'll start
having
a zoom meeting room start having regular
meetings and
etc so it
this is where the actual work takes
place once once the
steering committee voted to give you
that as a developing standard you then
try to get
people interested in the topic and
capable of
um contributing come together and you
have
regular meetings you develop a standard
you develop implementations
it's sort of an iterative process until
you're
till you're sort of happy with what you
have
you have some code you show it works you
have a document that lists out what the
standard should look like
and you have all the documentation you
then go back to the original
people who you collect who you had at
the beginning of this
journey security
then in this case that was very
important
they did a very very close and thorough
review of
of the standard we had actually picked
one of our product review committee
members from the security work stream so
they had a good idea
throughout the process of what we're
doing which made this a bit easier
but once they were happy regulatory and
ethics was not a huge deal
for a file format that's more important
than for example data discovery
and things like that
once you're past that and you think
you're ready
your product review committee has to
review it again
they they comment on it they have
experiences with your own standards they
support
etc and there's also an open review
where the public can go and and comment
criticize
uh whatever on the standard so again you
go back
you address those and that's an
iterative process
eventually you go back to the steering
committee you view a presentation
um they have seen all the documentation
and again
they vote yes or no
and if they vote yes it is approved as a
standard you then have standard version
1.0
and you're going towards trying to
outreach encourage adoption
usage etc um a quick word on the
numbering scheme that is being used
so you start out with 1.0
and it's pretty standard so minor fixes
would get you to 1.0.1
from a major but compatible update would
get you from 1.0 to 1.1
if there are too many changes which
would mean the next version of your
standard is incompatible
it breaks the compatibility then you
would go from version one
to version two but version one to
version two is treated as a whole new
standard so you have to go through the
whole process again and
explain and convince people that this is
actually a worthwhile
enterprise why break something that
people are already using etc
um in my case flip4gh so we have a lot
of implementations out there
there's uh python rust there's a java 13
implementation
there is htslip or c-based
implementation available that allows you
to build some tools that can read and
write crypto dh directly
there's a java 11 version there's a fuse
layer
there's some proof of concept hsjdk
support
and i'm supposed to be working on on
icarl and jtk as well
yes i have time um
there are challenges but in level of
time i just want to go
here if you're if you're curious about
what this file format is capable of
doing how it is being used at the moment
you can just google for crypt 4gh there
is a
there's a presentation we gave at last
year's plenary
there's a poster and there's also now a
paper in bioinformatics application note
that introduces
the standards to the community
and yeah that's really really
in summary i just want to say that
geofogh really covers tries to cover
all aspects of genomics but but not by
burying everything in standards but to
keep the number of standards at a
minimum
and make every one of them as useful as
possible we're not trying to create
anything that's not necessary
it's an open organization everything is
open meeting notes are open meetings are
open
if you are interested i encourage you
very much to to join
to contribute uh and code contributions
are welcome at all times as well
thank you
thank you very much alexander that was a
wonderful and
very encompassing talk so i
would like to remind people to ask
questions in the q a box
if you have any um or via the chat
and we'll address them as we go along
and maybe to give people a bit of time
to compose their thoughts
i had a couple of questions that i
wanted to quickly follow up on
um so you already mentioned the crypt
for gh reference implementations
and you said okay there have to be
multiple driver projects to
show that there's adoption um and
they have to be quite diverse so
do you find it difficult to drive
adoption in the wider community
or to to find sort of outside projects
that are willing to to implement
the reference standard or um do you have
like some ideas around that it's
a mixed bag i must say so
generally speaking when we present this
at conferences people are
people like it they like the idea of it
but then you have on the one hand the
large organizations that say
oh we are iso 27001 we have triple
firewalls
you have all our hard drives are
encrypted we don't really have a need
for it
so we have those people who have thought
about security in in the past decade
already
and then we have smaller projects which
don't really have the manpower to
contribute
who say this is exactly what we need
when can we use it
um so finding
finding people who are both interested
and and have the bandwidth to contribute
code wise is is not easy we are lucky
enough that there is at least three or
four
places now who were contributing to the
code
but there could always be more so for
example i don't think there's a demo yet
for
for a python based um pytham
implementation that uses crypt4gh
directly
something like that
and then i actually had a follow-up
question about that and
i think you uh went into the direction
quite well but
you mentioned explicitly ga4th does not
pass judgment about how valid or
preferred these implementations are but
have there any
been any talks of adopting some of the
implementations as the standards
and maybe auditing the codes or even
doing some formal verification
to say like hey this is really trying to
test it and you should use
this so there's discussions about that
but generally speaking we don't want to
get into that
because it is just something that
doesn't scale
um what we do say is we have
so for example we have two reference
implementations that that we
where we it along with the standard
itself so we we say those are
something we would use if you
if you implement it it's great but we
can't go into more details
so there's discussions on on sort of
having endorsements
but but those are still at the beginning
in recent
months there have also been some
programmers that have been hired the
geofogh organization
so that gives us a bit more scope to
actually go in that direction
but it's a slow process yeah
thank you um in the meantime i see
there's a couple of
questions in the chat box so for some
reason
the q a box has stopped
working or something but i'll read out
the questions
so leandro asks is there a centralized
mechanism
to validate that a given implementation
of the
format complies to a minimum set of
requirements
defined by the format so maybe going in
the same direction and
sort of overlapping with my question
so so there is not and
but that varies depending on standard
um so the cloud workstream for example
it's working on a framework we do
precisely that so they have
um a set of standards to to run
workflows and they're creating a
framework where you can plug in
an implementation and see if it produces
the outcomes expected
some standards have test data
with known results so you can use that
to to show that your implementation
complies
and some have nothing so it really
varies depending on the individual task
that is involved here there's nothing
centralized though
okay and a question from ola alex
what is your take on the discussions
around the
mpeg-g format that's actually an
interesting
topic because that's a direct competitor
to cram
and in in the beginning the cram
maintainer was
contributing to mpeg-g until he realized
that what they were doing is just trying
to
register patents left and right and so
he went out
and showed that nearly all of them were
actually prior art and they were already
implemented in cram
so the the relationship between the two
has
sort of soured a bit um
[Music]
i i don't think necessarily it's a bad
idea to have two standards
but if if you have the choice of of an
open standard that is supported by the
community and one where you have to pay
for usage
i think my preference would be to have
it open
for everyone to use out of the box
thank you um in the meantime i
don't see any further questions coming
up
so i think that might be it um
so with that in mind thank you very much
again alexander for the talk um
as well as vincent for the first talk
and with that i think we are at the end
of our discussion
um so thank you again very much for
coming
thanks to our speakers for giving
wonderful talks and
we hope to see you uh for next month's
meetup
as well and i hope you have a good
remainder of your evening
and goodbye see you next time
bye bye everyone
thank you bye
you